[Music]
people think that hardcore pornography
only exists in this modern digital age
but as soon as the motion picture camera
was invented people were making
pornography with it and selling it is
that true only a few years after burry
recently um 1908 was the very first
French film called at the golden in it
kind of depicts a happy little maid
cleaning cleaning the bedroom and then
she discovers well she's got a vacuum
and she can use this vacuum in the very
first she discovers a vacuum cleaner
she's using her happy vacuum cleaner do
they even have vacuum cleaners in 1908
only a couple of years ago 1901 was when
the first domestic vacuum cleaner came
out as porn as new technologies invented
porn follows right after right on the
heel boy yeah well no it's fascinating
to me that they someone invented the
vacuum cleaner in 1901 a few years later
they invent the camera and it's like a
year after that they're making a
pornographic film Oh together with a
vacuum cleaner
you brought a clip of that so then film
should we take a look let's take a look
why not
[Music]
the message the electorate's your
attention right electric bass guitar had
not been invented yeah yeah how many
genres genres it feels like the one
difference is that in the new era there
are many more genres of pornography that
people with very peculiar specific
fetishes can find whatever they want is
that a true assumption yeah well the
Victorians are the one that have been to
John Roos for us I mean they invented
schoolgirls mating confession version
confession birching in which a little
boy gets spanked but he was at school
and they kind of went off of that and
now we just have super hyper specialized
porn now somebody who's really into
rubber Ducky's commissioned a porn
company to make a porn of rubber duckies
somebody who's into other things
insect-borne I'm sorry to have to live
through this let me know when a rubber
ducky thing comes out yeah I have a
question for you how do librarians react
to you because I imagine you go to
library a lot for your studies and say
give me everything you've got about the
maidens being whipped with a birch
British Library in London I asked them
for all their books on school girls they
looked at me rather disapprovingly and
then they made me sit about 10 inches
from them to make sure I wasn't going to
run off and masturbate in the corner and
then they locked it in a chest every
time I went up to bathroom
Brian what do you want to do with your
life it's this way he's finding out a
lot of fascinating stuff you seem too
low a lot Conan I believe in being a
Renaissance man we should know a little
bit about everyone that includes
pornography then so be it
you